number 99 on your program number one in
your heart look who's here in person
show warren sapp pro football
you actually remember that sad person
you're special i love you are you
kidding me good to see you always good
to see you baby here uh brockman del
tufo tj
this is the way this is the way these
things get booked
sometimes
i'm gonna let people in on on i'm gonna
let people in on how sometimes the
sausage gets made we're gonna lift the
hood up a little bit okay so uh i show
up for work yesterday five ish in the
morning
and um
i go into the new nfl network studios
and by the way the new locker room that
they built for us is remarkable
oh gosh
okay so
so it's one of those things where i grab
my suit that i was planning on wearing
i'm planning on wearing this suit i
thought to myself i've only got like
three suits there i didn't bring one on
my i said i'm locked in i'm wearing this
suit
i put the suit on it's blue pinstripe
suit
who is in the makeup chair in a much
thinner blue pinstripe suit same color
michael irvin
i'm not changing he's not changing oh no
okay
then i go back into the locker room area
who's putting on his blue suit moochie
kurt warner oh mooch is already in his
basement
he's already dressed
he might have gone to sleep
so we all show up on the set and we're
like all wearing the same suit and i
started the show by saying we're locked
like literally we're knuckled up before
the whole thing starts well i say this
is going to be a great addition to nfl
game day morning because we all knew
that the other person was wearing a blue
suit after we put one on and none of us
changed so we are locked in i mean
all right so now two hours into the show
my phone buses
who is it mr warren sack
here are the three texts i will read it
out
all blue suits no like
[Laughter]
we never the same in clothes or thoughts
exclamation points next one
fix it
[Laughter]
in other words don't let me see it again
that's what i'm saying
i know you couldn't fix it
[Applause]
don't let me look at that set again with
the nice new blue awning and whatever
they've
[Laughter]
broke back game day in l.a my buck's in
l.a me too
exclamation point lamb is on the menu
baby
with mint jelly
oh
is what he says and then i i immediately
said if you're in town you want to come
in come on and lo and behold there he is
that's how it works
warren sapp is here in studios
yes indeed i'm glad
hey man you got to stop that kevin
durant reading people text messages on
air like this
rapper too y'all gotta stop that thing
no text messages
it's all good you can read mine i'm good
oh no especially since you're like you
know you're all wearing the same suit
you know like that was so funny of
course i read it to earth
oh my gosh did i hit curtain you know he
hit me back with my favorite you know
black quarterbacks
i can't believe russell whistle off that
game are you kidding me
i know right kirk cousins won that one
yesterday and so uh but you went to the
game oh yeah correct you were there it's
so funny i had to go to the
you know what i i've been judging
stadiums i'm a tailgate guy now yes i
yo i see your instagram let's say this
mercedes-benz stadium is very very nice
but oh my the jones my hall we know that
it's nice yes it is
so fast got it
oh my god correct right oh my god
there's nothing better it's like they
put a hole in the ground put a stadium
and then put a hat over the top of it
and then the wind blows through it
like a buck hat too you know it goes
into that little nice mohawk oh my the
wind blows through it oh my god it's an
outdoor stadium
absolutely outdoors the wind blows you
can feel that that that that that marine
air oh and the canopy lets the sun in
too it's not it's not like a no uh you
know a solid canopy you get it all it's
unbelievable oh my god and you gotta
experience it but i'm wondering what you
thought because you know i said on on
this show a couple weeks ago i wasn't
around you know in the 70s when
sinatra's smoking heaters on the
sideline with jack youngblood you know
whatever the home field advantage might
have been in the 70s in the coliseum
this is the greatest home field
advantage the rams have ever had in los
angeles tell me why their mascot is
upside down from this house
i don't have an answer right
now
i mean well the chargers don't show up
there with theirs upside down because
they're on that side right i guess so i
i don't have an answer for you warren
but but to me though
that is they're rocking a significant
advantage
and they're playing like he's playing so
daddy got a quarterback too and that
speed oh
you got to deal with the rounds do you
think the rams are the best you got to
do with the rams do you think the rams
are the best team in the nfl listen
right now yes they they're playing
they're playing very very good football
right and when you can put up 34 points
like that and then hold that offense we
got down mm-hmm that's how you win games
because i always said with tom brady and
that offense we got you need 30 to play
with us and they put up 30.
i mean that's what you got to do that's
the new nfl if you can't score 30 you
can't get in the game and stafford does
appear to be the guy that they wanted to
bring there oh no i mean he threw the
ball like that in detroit but they
didn't have 99 on the other side and you
know jaylen ramsey and the other pieces
and those young db's they have back
there the ability to go out and play
defense with him it was him and megatron
i mean the guy he threw the ball to was
so bad we named him a bad guy everybody
won't be batman and superman this man
was a nine millimeter guy in that trap
right i mean he was just that bad but
with sean mcvay's innovative way to to
get his people in positions
if you can't rush him
you're dead warren tap here on the rich
eisen show how what makes okay how good
is aaron donald walk me through why he's
oh my goodness
his balance
his anticipation his knowledge i know he
watches a ton of film and then he
doesn't sell it short
except in the run game
a little bit in the run game you know if
you i mean it's 275 pounds that's one
thing that me and jeff christie was
talking about he's like billy he's still
only 275 pounds i said but you got to be
willing to lean on him for four quarters
and bring your offense back and most
teams aren't willing to do that you want
to go up the field you want to go attack
and put him one-on-one
he's the best thing i've ever seen
really you've ever seen yeah rush in the
past oh no doubt about it
no doubt about it he didn't even close
inside
hmm i mean me and johnny talked about it
that kid did oh
every oh man
i love the way he gets on the edge and
flips and goes
i love his motor but i just wish he'd
play that run a little bit more what do
you mean
chicago bad game he he swims on the goal
line comes over the top grabs the
running back and he drags him in the end
zone for a touchdown mm-hmm
oh you'll never see that play
so he's got room for improvement oh no
there's always room for improvement he's
the best thing going but you're going to
share a bus room with him one day right
oh no doubt about it no question i'll
join him in all in dead week i mean does
his spot off baby come on he said
oh my goodness he's that special and i
always hear you know you echo in my head
quite a bit on game day morning no
seriously and we all say it too you know
we still we still say the sappisms all
the time and one of them is the front
and the back end have to play together
right so how how does he how do he and
ramsay work
again we're going to have to see this
that they're they're about to get into
the deepest end of the pool in terms of
division play
that's what that's what that's what
probably hits the road correct and
that's where
aaron donald and janet ramsey and that
front and that back end yeah must come
together because you're going to play
russell wilson
and you know what deep ball he throws
and the protection they're going to
provide him and then his ability to move
around right so now with that clock in
the quarterback's head jaylon ramsay
could take those chances those dbs can
now break on those routes and play the
sticks you know when it's third and
seven they're not going for 18 right
they're going for seven and if you got
somebody that can put pressure on the
quarterback and he's got to get rid of
that ball that's when that pick six
happened warren sapp here on the rich
eisen show first ballot pro football
hall of famer so uh how good are the
cardinals because they're 3.02 warren
and you just mentioned about deep ball
and you mentioned about quarterbacks
that can run around
kyler murray is an mvp candidate right
now three weeks in i think when the hell
gave him aj green
right
i mean the wrist just keep getting
richer i mean you kidding me i know why
aaron rodgers is going crazy over green
bay i'm winning this with hood ornaments
in 46 seconds on the clock and no
timeouts
unbelievable boy
unbelievable
john lynch has to be pulling his hair
out to watch his defense give up that i
mean that's taylor made for defense in
arizona
that kid behind quarterback calamari and
then the weapons you give him with
hop and aj green
and he's like a running back himself
yeah
no no then you go on the other side of
the ball right and chandler jones is
playing like a madman what he did to uh
tyler living or whoever both tackles
right you know they switched tackles the
the backup tackle should be fired yeah
taylor lewan yeah the lawrence oh my
goodness and jj watts there too listen
and jj watch there's a hood ornament in
this thing right now
he's inside doing his thing but
let me ask you this question warren is
chandler jones a hall of famer
you know what he's got over a hundred
sacks
so does simeon rice and a bunch of other
guys you know john abraham and a bunch
of other guys got over 100 stacks i mean
that can't be the measure anymore
i can't i mean you got to be your impact
on the game and it was once said to me
can the nfl story be told without you if
it can't then that makes you a hall of
famer
and right now we could tell the story of
the whole the nfl without chandler jones
so you're saying he has another five or
10k he had the other day i mean you just
have to put a body of work that revels
the great ones that played i mean we
talked about kevin green third all-time
god god bless you so you know what i'm
saying guys like that played this game
ricky jackson played this game we took
157 sacks we talked about johnny randall
with 137. you know 100 ain't the number
no more you know demarcus why had 100
was one of the fastest 200 wasn't he
but now where's the 150.
warren sapp here on the rich eisen show
how do you think the loss yesterday is
sitting in tampa what happens now is
brady heads to new england of all places
to take his anger out
um it'll be something to build up this
next few days here antonio brown should
be back
so when you have a full slate of
weapons and is broke all right
he's he came back in the game which is
kind of crazy you know when you're
getting blocked though i know
when it's grown you don't even question
it right is he tough and dumb enough to
do it so warren you've never seen him
get hit like that before though have you
boy
that was one of those shots that yeah
you know the older you get the more
affecting those shots
have on you but we'll see what it is in
78 because you know he wants to go back
to new england and do work too so right
brown two and two
everybody wants to go do work so let's
let's lock this thing up but let's not
underestimate bill belichick and his
ability to be able to pick somebody's
playbook around what do you think
belichick as you know takes the one
thing that you want away from you we
talk about that all the time and brian
billick
always got upset whenever we mention
that he goes the rest of us coach is
what we'll let you we'll let you have
the one thing that you would like to do
like where he's the only one who takes
it away
but um what do you think
him knowing about what brady likes to do
perhaps more than anybody else
what do you think he's going to try to
do on sunday night against this offense
that you know brady coming off of this
game
will want to put some points on the
board
what do you think i'm fascinated with
this one because it's not just brady
that he's going up against
it's left wish and b.a
i mean they all gonna put their thing in
this and
somebody's gonna give him the tendencies
in which he's done it they're gonna lay
it in front of them they have to because
you can't go back to the hen house and
not expect you know bill to have a
little couple tricks up his sleeve for
you i mean
they spent 19 years together
mm-hmm
right and he's going to be in the
visitor's locker room
hey and for some reason you know i'll
give you a story yeah we got ready to go
to foxborough with tony dungy the start
of the 2000 keyshawn's first game with
us
there's a ben right outside the
bus
throw your playbook in the bin tony
dunchy says to us
all our offensive guys throw your
playbook in the bin she sean goes crazy
oh my god i said relax keith
relax what's going on man man he took my
playbook man i said relax you got to
know the plays now yeah yeah i know i
should relax baby whatever tony got for
us
it's a plan
tony get there and we standing in front
of the room and you know i had i said
something i said he's freaking out coach
you gotta you gotta explain why you took
his playbook so tony explains he said
well
if you look at the history of all teams
that come to visit new england they're
down 10 to 14 points in the first
quarter i don't know how this is but it
just tends to happen a bunch of times
and you know you got 53 guys on a team
and a bunch of playbooks in the first 15
and somebody in the back and they get
mad and they ball them throw in the
corner
it's picked up and some kind of way it
gets over there
so you've seen somebody upset with the
plays because the playbook is right
there and you see the first 15 they're
not there no no i'm just saying
tony dungy said we ain't taking no paper
to new england to show our first 15 or
any of our play books we had shots
we left them in tampa we had sean
merriman come on uh on the show last
week said that uh any of the chargers of
the you know the era of him being in san
diego uh they got fined if their
playbooks were left in their uh hotel
room oh that was the whole point of it
is that
they got you know of
housekeeping or that's when somebody
picked it up it got the bill
oh it got to the news
how does that really i'm just telling
you the game we played we was up 10 14
nothing and then they came back at the
end of the game and lost it like 21-17
or something like that yeah
yeah
no no paper nowhere tony dungey
left it in tampa the bucket the bin was
in front of the bus before before we
went to the airplane before we got to
the plane
was going crazy i can't start in my
playbook man
oh you gotta know the plays by now so
you think brady's telling tampa
something oh i promise you they're not
going up there with no no no paper they
shouldn't
[Laughter]
are you concerned about the chief's
defense yeah your name yes okay very
much so
because the one thing that
you need to do is come up with enough
stops to get patrick mahomes in that
offense right
the ability to do what they're doing how
does one fix a defense when they come
out of the gate so
um
that's it
go back to the drone bug whenever we had
a bad game
it was a work wednesday we line that
thing up and we're gonna go to work
we're gonna go to work on it we're gonna
get our pad level down we're gonna stop
this run and then we're gonna mount a
rush to the quarterback
because that's just the game blocking
and tackling and doing the things that
are fundamentally sounding that defense
is just
out there living the life because they
have tariq hill and patton holmes on
that side that's all that is come on
let's just be honest no no defense out
there
i like the rams what they doing you know
what i'm saying sure of course that's
what you do you go out and you lock
people down and you go after the
quarterback i mean you don't go out and
be like okay my offense is scoring you
know we're looking for picks and
unfundamentally sound no leverage i mean
come on
fourth and five
no four foot four have a false start
it's four for nine and they're just on
the edge of field goal race they're
going for it
i'm like this is the ultimate disrespect
first of all you lined up for it one
fourth and four and now you get a false
start now you're gonna go for it on four
foot nine and get it and then score a
touchdown on me don't even think about
kicking the ball
wow so you're not concerned about the
chiefs making
their usual hay this year or you are
what do you think you know what it's
early but the signs aren't good
the signs aren't good because the
raiders are 3-0
i mean how really that do you think
listen with max and that defense hunting
like that underneath bradley john's
gonna find a way to score some points
that's just what john does i mean he has
a quarterback and some weapons around
him that i mean that tight end come on
when you got a match up nightmare in the
middle of the field now that opens up
the outside and that's what john wants
to throw the ball
trust me okay so the raiders are for
real oh yeah three weeks in
um
chiefs are in trouble because that
defense is lackadaisical and finally
mahomes is human in september
13 and old all touchdowns no
interceptions something wild like that
hadn't lost that and throughout big
interceptions in the fourth quarter and
we know he's a better quarterback than
that we do yeah i agree i agree so who's
the best team in the afc you're in on
the bills who are you in on right now
not all in on anybody but because the
headless horseman allen in in buffalo
does some crazy stuff for quarterback
i mean that's what i call the headless
horseman sometimes
there's no way you allow your offensive
coordinator to call that flip play
against pittsburgh week one come on man
get out of here you gotta you gotta be
like coach come on we got a better play
than that i mean that's just what it is
and then he does some crazy stuff but
it's early and you know we started the
season three and four three years in a
row and still make the playoffs so
don't don't don't listen to warren y'all
and you no i mean no but you are one of
them
kc you got to do something with that
defense that's crazy because there's a
17th regular season game and we don't
know we don't know how deep uh an owen
two hole really is owen three's a
totally different ball of wax doesn't
matter how many games there are i
totally understand that
one and two might be something that is
easily come back from as opposed to
previous years unless
you know
you're a team like i guessed say
the steelers
what do you think about roethlisberger
end of last year beginning of this year
i'm more concerned about that defense
that looks unrecognizable for me
24 points
for the cincinnati bengals and heinz
field
what is going on
i mean the back the front end the middle
ain't nothing working in pittsburgh and
you know not to even speak of the other
side that's unfamiliar too because
there used to be a run
run
and then attack you would play action
pass then it became ben ross's burger
and a.b going off and now was juju
schuster
now is clay claypool now why
what what is their identity
what i mean ben's getting old
and you can't let him keep getting hit
because you know he likes to get hit in
munch houses
he really likes the munch houses
explain what you mean by the munchau is
that well you know like you're on your
last leg and you you know i i will us
the victory you know the willis reed you
know willa's reading school any points
in that game
[Laughter]
[Music]
just him showing up
but that's that's that that's that much
housing effect when you come in and you
know ben likes to limp around and you
know throw people off or whatever but
he's gotta get rid of that ball all
right get that ball out of his hand he's
more than capable of getting it but
they're in trouble cincinnati 2014 oh my
goodness i know it's kind of crazy what
do you think happens tonight eagles and
cowboys what do you think happens to
good old nfc east yep battle
should be fun to watch with these two
quarterbacks but i love the eagles front
that prescott will have more pressure on
him than he had in the cowboy game and
out here so far they got they got a
front in philadelphia no kidding yeah
they i've watched them because you know
i like watching frontiers like the cox
is over there so i like fletcher and
they got some guys over there that are
rushing right now i can't name them
right now but what's them tonight
you know i'm not going with names i
don't want to go yelling at who beat 97.
who is my man who was my man in uh in
buffalo is that kyle williams oh
my man remember that one k williams when
you were you were you were doing your
breakdown and then you were just like
the name exactly what you said and your
name flew out of your head and you know
that flew out of my head they didn't
pick them for me that was the last time
i lie
my man
that said the man name and then he put
kate williams up there i'm like really
all right so uh nba media day today
brockman what happened when uh doc
rivers and daryl mori spoke today what
what went down
hearing for the first time from the guy
uh who has not traded ben simmons yet
what do we have over there all right
daryl mori on ben simmons he is quote a
great player and we expect him back we
expect him to be a 76er
daryl said he spoke to ben in a meeting
quote six to seven weeks ago the last
time he's put them on the pano mine list
for six to seven weeks now
he's not coming back
he's not coming back joel embiid said
you know obviously disappointing how it
goes he loves playing with ben makes
them a better team wishes he would
return but understands that's how things
work these wait wait is this the
business that can't shoot
it's not the one who can't shoot it's
the one who shoot that's the wall
that was the one that however you want
to say
his difficulty i mean they said it was
ace and kid because he didn't have a j
he was shooting
i mean they always said jason kidd
didn't have a j either but magic johnson
didn't have one either but you know you
got to shoot it embiid said that he's
spoken to him right he's he's
communicated to him that he he wants him
there right why so he can keep passing
it to him and not shooting
no i want to win a championship give me
a guard that's going to shoot it in the
fourth quarter give me a guard that i
can pick and roll let's go pull up and
let that thing go from 15 18 foot and
then let's go back down the other way
four years left on this deal
oh they always throw away a bunch of
money you remember the whole bocce grill
was getting all that money up in
washington and then came over
he came in the locker room with the guns
yeah yeah
nothing new for the nba what else
happened chris anything else uh in
brooklyn uh kevin durant was there
david letterman also there
what do you mean david letterman started
asking kevin durant a bunch of weird
questions where was he like on a zoom no
no he was physically there
it was so wait a minute david letterman
showed up in brooklyn today yes as part
of the
media day for the brooklyn nets yes and
asked him questions yes
physically there not on a zoom like he
showed up yeah he was there physically
he got a press pass it's hilarious here
we have video roll tape
dave
from basketball digest kevin uh
uh kd why why do people call you k.d
um can i call you kd or yeah okay my
first name is kevin
right
my second my last name
my second name my last name is durant or
the d k.d
uh this year how what percentage do you
plan on giving on the court
90 95 100 110 what are we looking at uh
110 110 i just got off the phone with
the dolan family
and they said that they're talking to
the commissioner now they're looking at
working a contractual deal that will
allow you
uh when you're not playing for the nets
days off you'll be able to play for the
knicks comments
all right dave that was the last one
i'm sorry was that a comment
because it how about you do you have a
comment
wrap it up okay
uh i'm being told my time is done have a
great uh year what about the pelicans
when you guys play the pelicans it's
gonna make you giggle
yeah okay all right that's all i got
david letterman is come on you got to
have fun with david letterman are you
kidding me
dave he can't be sick i mean come on two
things first of all
first of all
i miss david letterman everybody we all
do single sessions
of the day we all do
my second one is there he is look at him
that's david letterman
sitting there in yellow mustard pants
sure skinny field jack he's got like the
skinny phil jackson with a big giant
giant beard still yeah very gray that is
david letterman physically there for
whatever he he's doing
but you got to have more fun with david
letterman why do they call you he had to
have no ken he had to they've only been
john what five years six years no no how
long has dave how long has dave been
gone from the late night scene two days
oh it's been no it's been about five
years no believe it or not it's more
than that longer than that yeah lower
than that
at least 15 2015 six years six years
yeah
the world knows who he is
maybe not maybe he was in on the joke i
think so i think when you kind of look
at his face yeah but he we didn't get a
smile into this he said that's the last
one
[Music]
i mean that was amazing he's totally
wrapping up he's really funny wrap it up
b
well in brooklyn you've got to throw
that b in there sap you know that's come
on of course i mean look at it
the knicks would allow you to play for
them on them
that's hilarious
[Music]
they were just talking about a top 10
list the other day i came up with that
top ten list you did you did the first
kimmel right
yeah the first ever jimmy kimmel me
snoop dogg don bishop magic wand
[Laughter]
it was right after the super bowl right
yeah
my first helicopter
because it was on abc's yeah right after
this year
i landed at highland high school yeah
and now
that was
that was when they had the full bar
right like they had a full bar and
everything's like a party ball the
kimmel green room is well covered
i mean that must have been a green room
right zap oh you smell these cookies
[Laughter]
snoop
that room kept you lifted me in the
championship of the magnum bottle of
chris styles oh behavior two n l animal
style was that one of those things where
they called you before and say if you
win we want you in the helicopter oh no
no they they had set it up they'd they
set
it up yeah so who was the writer that
was going to go i don't know
who was that it's not for me to know
for me to stop
[Applause]
what about the rumor that al davis
changed the game plan night before
you heard about that one
no it was um
that barrett robin's error dreaming that
he had already won the super bowl with
one shot and was on his way to
uh tijuana or something like that yeah
loretto you know wherever he was going
the center of the team just totally no
no no
imagine that you dreamed that you
whooped me and you never woke me
i'm sorry that's right it's about you my
bad
you ran over the tampa bay buccaneers
you had a trash tap or two and now you
already in mexico and we didn't play the
game
i love it yeah they were supposed to run
us over that was the game plan because
we were little
and then not not so much
well then they went back to rich gannon
the two-time mvp of the league with
jerry rice and tim brown and jolly and
uh
what's the boy garner kaufman napoleon
called my friend yeah
come on you don't you don't come out
there who you going running with
tyrone wheatley i know you're at
michigan
[Music]
you don't talk college football the
minute we have left do you why not my
canes are dismal right now i told you we
have an identity crisis right now rich
we have a
cuban
coach that speaks no spanish
so you have the wrong coach is what
you're saying no
you know what i really like what kurt
hirsch said until we have a president
athletic director that's from the top
down that's devoted to our football
program like it was when
sam jankovic and foote and some of the
other people that was there you know
donna chilela you know with a brilliant
mind and everything turned to school a
different way and got us into you know
getting more money than we ever did we
top four top 50 right now in money
outside of football so
i understand that the bills are being
paid and it's not being paid with
football but we'd really like to see the
canes go kick some ass every now and
then
warren sapp here on the rich eisen show
thanks for coming on warren i'm sorry
you're the best nope
what are you sorry for
don't almost made it that's okay you
just you know my canes baby
i know it brings it out the doors agreed
baby that's why i'm going thursday i
will not be here to see the raider go
raiders
chargers have nothing for us hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here